To see some concrete
examples of interpolation,
I've put together this little app,
and it has two spinners here.
The first one has a list of a bunch
of different interpolators like
accelerate, decelerate, bounce,
decelerate, linear, overshoot.
And the second spinner
has different timings,
from 100 milliseconds all the way
up to 3,000 milliseconds or
three seconds, so that you can see
how fast or how slow things work.
So if we just select 3,000 milliseconds,
it's going to be really slow.
And just like Roman was saying in the
previous video, it's kind of gratuitous
to, and it's just too much motion to
be bouncing up and down that much.
So let's try, maybe a 900 milliseconds.
That looks a little bit better.
So let's switch to the code and
see how this works.
So here's the code that makes that work.
We start off with creating a new
instance of our interpolator.
Because it's different based off of what
the name is, we actually use the Java
class forName to get the class and
then instantiate a new instance.
But if you were using this in your
own app, you would call, say,
new BounceInterpolator directly.
So after we have that,
we call animate on our text view, and
set the interpolator and
the duration from our spinner, and
tell it to start in 500 milliseconds and
to move the animation from the bottom
of the screen, and then start.
Check the instructor's notes for
more information about interpolators or
this sample app
that you can play around with to see
how they work a little bit better.